te pregunto
hay algo en tu vida que sabes es
importante realizar pero lo has venido
procrastinar evadiendo o ignorando
busca bien en tu mente debe ser algo
realmente importante no puede ser ir al
banco libres anota lo que lo vamos a
retomar después
a todos nos llega un momento en la vida
en que recibimos un golpe uno de esos
que nos tumban a mí me llegó a los 25
años después de haber hecho todo lo que
había aprendido era necesario para hacer
éxitos en la vida era una mujer
disciplinada metódica perseverante y me
se diga lo persistente la fórmula de
estudia mucho esfuérzate buscó
oportunidades encuentra un buen trabajo
que te pague bien todo lo había cumplido
y un poquito más pero me llegó el golpe
me llegó en la forma de mi primer
fracaso y de mi lado ciego el lado
emocional al verme divorciada con menos
de dos años de casada yo no sabía qué
hacer con ese fracaso no lo podía
detener ni lo podía controlar entonces
que hice los tres me puse la máscara de
la fuerte la divertida la que todo lo
tenía bajo control y nada me afectaba
era diversión y viajes por fuera y por
dentro me llevaba a la soledad amargura
frustración e insatisfacción
pero así como nos llega el golpe también
nos llega el momento de la iluminación
puede ser en la forma de un consejo una
película o una conversación como fue mi
caso me conecté con una amiga en la
universidad y ella me comentaba cuando
su hija le recordaba como yo era una
joven valiente que se iba contra lo que
fuese sin importarle nada ni nadie que
hablaba tan poco inglés y yo buscaba
cuánta competencia y actividad yo
encontraba para solamente hacer me había
hablar el idioma
cuando termino esa llamada me di y yo no
reconocía a esa joven valiente ya me
había convertido en una mujer insegura
necesitada mendiga de amor y tan
dramática haberme visto así fue la punta
de lanza que desató mi camino de
recuperación hacia mi valencia
ese camino hoy me lleva a compartir con
ustedes tres etapas claves en toda
transformación pero estas tres etapas se
basan en la valentía por lo que voy a
hacer un paréntesis para que veamos todo
lo que la valentía puede hacer por
nosotros
te quiero pedir que me esa nota que
hiciste la nota mental y aquello que tú
sabes debes hacer pero has dejado creado
piense medio nuevamente
quiero informarte querido amigo querida
amiga que el evadir el procrastinar el
dejar el problema al lado a veces
aparece solo inclusive el decirte que tú
estás bien estás como no hay nada que
hacer o aplacarlo fingiendo felicidad
todas son formas de miedo por eso te
pregunto ahora a qué le temes que no te
deja avanzar
estás ante tu julia ese gigante que
parece que uno no va a robar jamás pero
si encuentras a la alta en ti entonces
estamos hablando negocios
este sentimiento de soledad interior que
yo tenía
es algo que es grave e importante en
nuestra vida ese sentimiento de soledad
estancamiento frustración rechazo
inclusive salió en un artículo en el new
york times' en el 2018 como la epidemia
de la salud moderna así de importante es
resolver el tema este sentimiento surge
porque nosotros centramos nuestra
existencia en nuestro propio ego y
entonces para poder desaparecer esos
sentimientos debemos aprender a
trasladarnos del yo al nosotros y eso
requiere de valentía
necesitas valentía porque te tienes que
enfrentar a ti mismo
tienes que romper y pisar a ese ego la
valentía es una cualidad y una capacidad
que todos tenemos y lo podemos
desarrollar y nos permite enfrentar y
soportar nuestros retos y dificultades
por encima de nuestros miedos la
valentía entonces como un compañero
verdad que nos da fortaleza cuando
nosotros estamos en búsqueda esas
situaciones incómodas que son las que
nos van a ayudar a evolucionar de hecho
a nosotros yo empecé con pequeños actos
de valentía como tirarlo a un paracaídas
para aprender a perder el control o
empezar a escalar para aprender a
confiar en mí y en otras personas
después que fue tomando confianza me
metí en las tormentas los cambios
significativos que me han permitido ver
tantas distintas versiones de mí para
ello yo hacía cosas como mudarme una
ciudad donde no conocía a nadie o pedir
un proyecto en donde yo sabía iba a
estar trabajando una oportunidad o con
una persona que representaba un reto en
fin la cuestión es buscar una situación
nueva y diferente que nos haga iniciar
de cero en algo
en esto de los cambios significativos
como en una tormenta se necesitan dos
masas de aire en distintos niveles de
temperatura es decir tu viejo yo y tu
nuevo yo dos situaciones distintas y
después cuando nos metemos en el cambio
es que nos metemos en el medio de la
tormenta donde empieza la presión lo que
genera los truenos y los relámpagos es
decir tus miedos y tus dudas
en este camino de tormentas entonces es
que yo te quiero sugerir que consideres
estas tres etapas claves la primera es
el autoconocimiento continuo no te
conformes ni te apegas a ninguna versión
de ti sino que mantente en constante
evolución de líder de tu vida en un
sentimiento de rendimiento de cuentas
contigo conoce tus principios como un ir
es tú mira tu vida y a tus miedos ponle
su nombre y apellido porque esa relación
es personal hay muchas herramientas que
pueden utilizar para conocerte mejor yo
descubrí la herramienta de la prueba del
eneagrama que interconecta nueve
distintos tipos de personalidad y sus
resultados que arroja no sólo tu tipo
pregunta predominante sino donde te
mueves en momentos de expansión y donde
vas en momentos de tensión
otra herramienta buenísima fundamental y
gratis es la evaluación diaria esos
cinco minutos antes de acostarte en
donde tú miras tu día y empiezas a
visualizar a aquellas personas o
situaciones que representan un reto y
que tal vez van interconectadas con algo
más profundo en tu vida eso te permite
identificar las áreas de potencial para
ser transformados luego de que tú
identificas estas áreas nos vamos a la
segunda etapa que es la práctica del
discernimiento donde eliges tu tormenta
aquella situación nueva y diferente que
va a desatar esa transformación que
buscamos
les cuento algo hace siete años yo vivía
cómodamente en la ciudad de nueva york
mi vida corporativa y social eran cito
afecta en bici di pero a mí me faltaba
algo era como un momento de
trascendencia y yo me encontré ante dos
decisiones o dos opciones perdón estaba
me quedo en eeuu que es lo como de
conocido o me regreso a casa a panamá
donde no vivía desde los 18 años de edad
la decisión se me complicó y yo decidí
buscar ayuda me guía me enseñó que yo no
me encontraba ante una decisión entre
algo bueno y algo malo sino que estaba
entre halcón bueno y algo mejor eso para
mí fue maravilloso no tiene vida o sea
fue liberador claro estaba ante dos
opciones igualmente buenas yo sólo
necesitaba detectar la diferencia
pero ya no terminó allí ella me le puso
cerecita al pastel cuando me advirtió
que tuviera cuidado
porque el gran problema del ser humano
es que se queda demasiado tiempo en
bueno por no soltar para agarrar algo
mejor
en esta práctica del discernimiento
nosotros buscamos bajar al ego y eso lo
hacemos mediante cuidar nuestras
preferencias y nuestros deseos y la
influencia que puedan tener en una
decisión entonces evaluamos cada
alternativa ante esta pregunta como me
permite esta opción servir a otros mejor
como me permite trascender con intención
cuando yo vi mis dos opciones viste mis
pros y contras contra esa pregunta mi
decisión fue fácil me regresaba a casa
qué mejor manera de amar y servir que
regresar unas familias que prácticamente
no me conocía ya un país donde me
quedaban muy pocas conexiones
profesionales
hoy 1º de agosto precisamente se cumplen
mis siete años de haber regresado a
panamá y ya entiendo porque se trataba
de un tema de trascendencia porque yo
aprendido a amar sin necesidad de
controlar y ayudar sino hacer luego de
que hemos detectado esas áreas con
potencial a ser transformadas elegimos
nuestra súper tormenta nos vamos a la
tercera etapa el momento de la acción
ese momento en que nos metemos en la
tormenta y aparecen los truenos tus
miedos tu golear que espero lo tengas
apuntado si no existe trampa en ese
momento yo siempre recuerdo el libro de
miguel ruiz los cuatro acuerdos donde él
nos regala el último acuerdo que nos
dice que hay que dar lo máximo posible
dando lo máximo posible
nosotros le metemos intensidad e
intención a todas nuestras acciones pero
también reconocemos que el máximo
posible de hoy tal vez no es el mismo
máximo posible de mañana
pero siempre nos encontramos dando lo
máximo
eso me transporta a mi tiempo escaladora
en uno de mis entrenamientos yo estaba
en la pared y yo gripe take take es el
comando que le indica a la persona que
está abajo que tiene que agarrar toda la
cuerda que cuelga porque tú te vas a
caer bueno eso era lo que yo pensaba en
ese momento pues resulta que mi
entrenador me bajó por completo al
inicio de la ruta para enseñarme lo
siguiente que uno no llama take antes de
la calidad sino en el momento de la
caída eso por qué porque cuando uno está
ahí arriba y los músculos ya que
tiemblan y tu mente te dice te vas a
caer te vas a caer
ese es el momento de justamente dar el
último impulso por la siguiente roca
porque si uno la logra agarrar de la
historia 1 de 2 a 3 movidas más
entonces te digo bebé por tu siguiente
roca así tú pienses que no lo vas a
lograr porque al menos habrás logrado
avanzar dar esos dos o tres pasos
adicionales que te dejan mejor preparado
para la próxima escalada pero yo soy
seguro que estás allí tuviese ya está
mujer me lo buenísimo pero caramba
todavía me da miedo este tema del salto
y del impulso es difícil especialmente
si estamos hablando de terminar una
relación de trabajo o emocional que
nosotros le hemos invertido tantos años
o imagines de siete quitarte una máscara
que con tanto esfuerzo mantenido
miren algo que les puedo decir es
verídico no falla en todas las tormentas
pequeñas o grandes que yo he pasado
siempre sucede y es que al momento antes
de dar ese paso magistral ya voy a
ejecutar estoy en el aeropuerto me
regreso para panamá me agarran las dudas
y qué pasa si me equivoco y qué pasa si
se burlan y si lo hago bien y si lo hago
mal todas esas cosas historias que nos
montamos en la cabeza son solamente
excusas y juegos de nuestra mente para
no dejarnos avanzar
entonces ese es el momento en que yo te
quiero regalar tres consejos
el primero alimenta tu auto-confianza la
autoconfianza es como una antesala un
preámbulo para la valentía está
comprobado con estudios yo mantengo un
archivo en mi computadora con los logros
y las dificultades que es sobrepasado y
cuando me atacan las dudas yo busco
evidencia de que yo tengo la capacidad y
que antes yo he podido vencer algo
similar segundo regalito
genera te compromisos estudios revelan
que cuando uno se siente responsable con
uno mismo o con otros eso eleva tu grado
de valentía por eso la gente habla de
manifestar de declarar verdad entonces
que te quiero decir yo yo aquí no
estuviera hoy con ustedes si yo no
hubiese hecho eso yo mandé mi aplicación
como para ver si ahora en el momento que
finalmente escribir y compartir esta
charla con ustedes y el último es que
siempre vuelvas a tu intención si ya tú
pasaste por el discernimiento y nos
preguntamos qué me ayuda a servir y
trascender entonces ahí está agárrate de
eso con fuerte ese es tu norte eso es lo
que te guía y te inspira los estudiosos
del heroísmo han encontrado esa
correlación entre el altruismo y tener
principios viene realizando espiral en
tiras
ahora quiero que conmigo por un minuto
viajes a este mundo que te quiero
presentar un mundo en donde cada
individuo ha logrado salir de sí mismo y
de sus miedos para sobresalir darse al
mundo con la intención de servir y
trascender en este mundo de valientes
las personas toman riesgos dan lo máximo
rinden acciones de sus actos y hacen lo
necesario en este mundo todos estamos
buscando oportunidades para evolucionar
y como estamos tan ocupados
trascendiendo y sirviendo no tenemos
espacio para actos de corrupción o de
desigualdad económica o de discriminar a
nadie sino que estamos continuamente
buscando este espacio solidario en donde
todos nos podamos realizar y no solo
unos pocos
quiero invitarte a que inicies tu camino
de valentía hoy iniciando o
responsabilizarte para conocerte
identificar esos talentos únicos que tú
tienes al igual que tus miedos y luego
yendo a buscar esas situaciones
incómodas que tú sabes te van a ayudar a
evolucionar y moverte del yo en nosotros
cuando lo hagas cuando te conviertas en
agente creador de tus tormentas recuerda
la maravillosa práctica del
discernimiento para que te centres en la
intención de servir y trascender y luego
da el salto a la acción dando lo máximo
y confiando en que tú ya tienes todo lo
que necesitas para completar tu misión
ahora te pregunto en cuanto a eso que me
anotas te que sabe este deshacer o
enfrentar pero lo has venido
procrastinar e ignorar te lanzarás con
valentía tomará acción a pesar del miedo
muchas gracias